âge en france on connaît donc depuis la
fin d'après midi le nouveau visage du
gouvernement à 18h30 l'elysée a annoncé
la liste des ministres de jean pierre
raffarin une équipe qui comprend 27
membres parmi les postes clés le
ministère de l'intérieur et de la
sécurité confié au député maire de
neuilly rosen calmes en
numéro deux du gouvernement nicolas
sarkozy a nommé ministre de l'intérieur
de la sécurité intérieure et des
libertés locales le rpr françois fillon
hérite lui du ministère des affaires
sociales du travail et de la solidarité
le maire de chalon sur saône dominique
perben devient garde des sceaux ministre
de la justice
l'actuel secrétaire général de l'elysée
dominique de villepin obtient le
portefeuille des affaires étrangères de
la coopération et de la francophonie
la présidente du rpr michèle
alliot-marie prend la défense et les
anciens combattants première femme à ce
ministère
l'écrivain philosophe luc ferry est
nommé ministre de la jeunesse de
l'éducation nationale et de la recherche
francis mer ancien président d'usinor
devient le nouveau locataire de bercy à
l'économie aux finances et à l'industrie
le maire udf d'amiens gilles de robien
arrive au ministère de l'équipement des
transports du logement du tourisme et de
la mer roselyne bachelot hérite de
l'écologie et du développement durable
le libéral jean françois mattei pédiatre
et généticiens obtient le ministère de
la santé de la famille et des personnes
handicapées hervé gaymard député rpr de
sa voix prend en charge l'agriculture
l'alimentation la pêche et les affaires
rurales le président du centre pompidou
le chiraquien jean jacques aillagon
ministre de la culture et de la
communication jean paul delevoye
président des maires de france est nommé
ministre de la fonction publique de la
réforme de l'état et de l'aménagement du
territoire
brigitte girardin peu connu du grand
public devient ministre de l'outre-mer
le double champion olympique du sabre
jean françois lamour obtient le
ministère des sports parmi les douze
autres ministres délégués secrétaire
d'état patrick devedjian secondes
nicolas sarkozy aux libertés locales
jean louis borloo le maire de valence n
devient ministre délégué à la ville
enfin jean françois copé est le nouveau
porte parole du gouvernement